on this episode I talk about bricks and
mortars I talk about almonds kids with
cash and some other stuff you ask
questions and I answer them this is the
askgaryvee show
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
welcome to episode 45 of the askgaryvee
show
before we go into today's episode I want
to give everybody a huge shout out for
all the support the last couple of days
on the big-screen television thanks for
watching me on Seth Meyers a lot of fun
I was on Bloomberg for an hour just a
couple of hours ago I know there's a
question today about that which I find
very real-time so thank you I appreciate
the love of the Vayner nation Joe asks
Gary what trends should brick-and-mortar
stores be paying attention to
over the next 12 to 18 months Joe's a
great question you know for me a lot of
people have been talking about the
second-screen situation with television
right like people watching TV with their
phone the funny part is they refer to
this as the second screen I think we're
about I'm probably about there now but
this is very much the first screen and
that's the second screen and we'll get
into that on a different show that was
kind of a little gateway drug for
somebody if they want to get on the show
that would be a good question to ask the
trend in retail for me is kind of now
the second screen shopping opportunity
what I mean by that is this your eyes
are the first screen what you're
actually looking at but think about this
one of the things that caught my mind a
few months ago was I was in a
supermarket and I watched somebody go
from one aisle to the other and the
whole time she was sorry deira she was
you know she was shopping and she was
doing this and she went around
yeah sorry India and she went around the
endcap now look brands pay a crapload of
money to get those end caps or have to
have the hottest product in the world
going but usually a big stores big
supermarkets big box stores they're
paying for that positioning because it's
the best position in the store those end
caps and so the second screen shopping
opportunity is really fascinating to me
right geo-located you know beacons in
the store you're in the store you're
shopping about you're getting messaging
I mean there's a lot of people who don't
want to be annoyed than their phone but
I'm sure plenty of people when there
invest buy or Target or Costco or an
Albertsons or Walmart whatever mind
getting a quick little text or
notification or if they're in their
Twitter stream there you
that you know geo-located data to
understand to push a tweet you're in
Walmart you get a tweet from Walmart
that's telling you you know there's this
deal and if you click this button and
scan it Apple pay
second screen shopping opportunities one
of the things I'm thinking about for
Wine Library is I'm kind of like getting
a little flirty with the wine world of
more and more coming inching back in
solo Steve loved the show Steve's
happiness of a face as I'm inching and
thinking more about why and I'm starting
to rethink about the score and the
thought of like walking in and getting
content and paying paying for wines
across the board in the store at a lower
price if you have the app at register
just second screen shopping is a very
big deal lisa says gary awesome segment
with Seth Meyers Lisa asks with all this
talk about snapcash what is the one
thing you'll teach your kids about money
thanks for the lovely sááá that's an
interesting question you know my parents
thought my mom actually really taught me
to respect money you know my dad for an
immigrant was a big thinker with money
in the business he really let me splurge
and take chances I give him a lot of
credit for that you know it's funny I
have a weird relationship with money I
want it I'm aware of its benefits but
I'm much more into the kind of like PR
legacy like you know where's my place in
the history much more so about the
dollars I think if you try to put
yourself in history the money finds you
very quickly you know I don't know I
mean my biggest fear is my kids are
gonna be rich
versus what I grew up with and so I'm
trying to figure out some level of
creating respect around it I guess the
only thing that's defaulting into my
mind is I'm gonna make those two work
they don't work so they earned their own
cash and then they can figure out what
their relationship is with their cash
hey GV its TF got a question for you for
all my friends in the real estate space
around the world and the question is how
much of my advertising marketing dollars
should I be spending on salespeople
telemarketing efforts versus direct mail
print traditional versus online you know
me buddy
no wrong way to generate leads kind of
guy what's your take on you know TS I
got to tell you I agree I mean obviously
I pushed new forward ways of thinking
about selling stuff whether it was
ecommerce back in 96 email marketing in
97 google adwords in 2000 banners then
content marketing in 2006 I mean people
are talking about content marketing now
I started Wine Library TV on February
21st 2006 to do content marketing so
obviously all the social stuff I got
peeps in the background too you know I
get it yeah I think that if you got away
I know we've talked in the past that
Direct Mail really works for you as a
channel agreed do it if that's working
for you I even did direct mail for Wine
Library 17 months ago just to make sure
it didn't bring any ROI and it was a
disaster like it was it was scary to me
we used to be Direct Mail juggernauts in
98 99 2000 where we'd get 3 4 5 6 7 %
redemption of how many Flyers we'd send
out people coming to the store we had
like six people bring the coupon to the
store and we had a big value prop in it
so like Direct Mail clearly died for us
and then other places have grown and sem
works and Facebook dark posts are
working and content clearly has worked
so I'm a no you know no romance over the
lead kind of guy as well I mean here's
my thing though people fall in love with
the way they've made their money right
because it's working right now like I'm
thrilled when I think that Instagram and
Facebook dark posts and Twitter suck
can't wait for that can't wait for 2024
you know when I'm like dissing on that
I'm like it's all about this the virtual
reality great can't wait in the words of
Bart Scott you know and so I think that
um I think the biggest thing that I get
scared about and is that people get
romantic and don't try new things every
person watching here should always be
spending between 5 to 20% of their money
if that's what you got or your time if
that's what you got a new and innovative
things because they need to be prepping
for 2016 2018 2022
here's the biggest key TF no matter what
you tell me your direct mail response
and telemarketing response is not as
good as that same action ten years ago
if you were doing that same calling in
the background and that same Direct
Marketing ten years ago it would have
had a bigger ROI because more people
were paying attention to those channels
their actual home phone and their
mailbox than they are now in a world of
this this and everything pulling away
not to mention the costs are higher in
Direct Mail because you know the post
office is subsidizing that loss of money
so these are the things that I think
about it's the arbitrage of the value of
the ROI not necessarily the action
itself
Davian asks Gary do you script answers
or improvise how much time do you invest
in prep their production per show they
mean you know here's how it goes down
Steve you know we're India in the future
might you know just run through the
questions I do want to have like once
you know it's funny I just did the
rapid-fire on Bloomberg as a matter fact
it's weird that we actually even read
the questions because I should prefer
them coming cold we may even go to that
I'm not sure why I do that but that's it
they were like here come the questions
cool maybe gives me a minute or two
while I'm answering this question
thinking about the next one because I
want to give it the best answers I
possibly can but I'm very comfortable
and improv I I prefer it I feel like
they're fresh I think one of the main
reasons you guys watch this show is
because I bring it fresh and real and I
think that matters and and that's pretty
much where I'm at
with the prep time in the production
that's the rock Stephane Newton new
addition is in the house
loves Kobe gotta figure that out but I
told me truth I'm starting to love Kobe
by the way when I don't have invested
interest in athletes or teams I always
root for the underdog and when I don't
have vested interest in teams
besides my two favorite teams left and
jets and Knicks if everybody in America
loves him or her and they're the best I
go against the grain like I hated Tiger
Woods until America hated him right I
just I just I just go the I'm just that
guy I just AM that
marius asks hey Gary can you explain in
more detail your statement from market
makers that Super Bowl ads are under
priced I sure can't Marius
I appreciate the question just moments
after I got off the set you know I care
about attention just like the questions
we just answered and so I think almost
everybody in America when the Super Bowl
at a Super Bowl party they're watching
it and then when the commercials comes
on you hear at parties
like the event is to consume the
commercial at the highest scale couple
years ago so I did not watch both Super
Bowls that include or no that's not true
the last Super Bowl that the Patriots
and Giants played in I didn't watch it I
just laid in my bed
they're like silently and it was surreal
because like I knew that all of America
was doing one thing and me and AJ were
doing another thing which was sitting in
silence and so I remember that really
drills home the fact for me that all of
America watches this game and then
watches those commercials and the
attention put on those commercials is
overwhelming and just the bottom line is
in that arbitrage of the ROI I truly
think that when you compare a Super Bowl
ad four or five million compared to
other ads hundreds of thousands that
this return is so much greater than
hundreds of thousands of dollars
millions of dollars that people spend on
television during the regular year when
everybody's DVR a when a commercial
comes on everybody's in here and so I
think it's underpriced by today's market
I just really do I think a Super Bowl ad
is if it's four or five million or what
they're charging these days I think it's
worth 10 to 20 I really do just the way
it is question of the day for askgaryvee
for five how many almonds are in this
jar and bad news for somebody in this
room you're gonna have to count them
stuff on your new guy
how many almonds are in this jar if
somebody actually gets a number in
school like we were growing out like I
don't I'm old I don't know if you guys
said this but then you guys have the
jellybean thing they still do that with
the youngsters amazing if somebody gets
it right I'll fly you to New York City
and I would let you sit right here and
be on the askgaryvee show that is how
confident I am that the vaynernation
cannot answer this correctly if you're
listening to the podcast you need to go
to youtube and watch the show so you can
get a good look at these guys promise
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe